In this course from Oliver Otchere you will
improve your Django and Tailwind CSS skills
by creating a Netflix clone. You learn how
to recreate the design of netflix and implement
some simple functionality. Hello wonderful
people. It's a OtchereDev, I decided that
Why shouldn't I create a Django clone of Netflix?
So I did that. You will know what Netflix
is. So this is Netflix the original website.
It says unlimited movies, unlimited TV shows
and more. So it allows you to watch movies
and TV shows. Okay, online. So this is the
original website of Netflix. And this is my
version of Netflix. Let me switch to that
So you can see from here that I'm running
on localhost. Local localhost port 8000. So
okay, so this is it. This is my version of
Netflix, you see this, it's almost like they
say, I needed a good record, it did well,
so it has the sign-in, the authentication
system, the authentication system baked in.
Okay, my PC is a little bit slow. So you guys
should pardon me. So I'm going to log in.
Okay, then provide my password. Login. Okay,
so you see, when you log in into if you have
used Netflix before, you'll be asked to choose
a profile. And because I've already tested
it, that's how it is so many profiles. So
you can add a new profile by going to this
clicking on this button, it's going to send
you to a page where you can create a new profile,
which is displays, but I don't want to create
a new profile. So I just go back and choose
any of the profile. So the profile, you have
two types of profile there. And I can watch
all videos and one profile for only kids.
Okay, so I just use this. Okay, so you see,
this is the homepage. Alright, can see. So
I just have to because I can't compete with
Netflix. So let me click on a movie. And it's
going to take me to the detail page of the
movie. So I clicked on Viking. So this is
the Detail page of I can see give me some
description about the movie. Now just some,
some placeholder text. And if I want to watch
the movie, this is the button here, I click
here, it sends me to the page where the movie
is going to be shown just like how Netflix
assets and this is it. Let me play. Okay,
it's, as you can see, right, it's playing
but the image that I use is just I just use
some placeholder image, video. So it's, it
shows nothing, but the one that we'll be demoing
here, you would use some shots, fake video,
so you can see this thing just popped out.
Okay, so this is basically what you're going
to build, you can expand upon it add payment
is of no lifting at any add on the payment
system and the magic behind that flavor that
I can't do anything about. So this is basically
what we are going to do, we're going to build
our own version of Netflix using jungle them
with the best framework ever. So guys, let's
jump into it. And let's do this the now. Okay
guys, so let's jump into the video and let's
create our own version of Netflix. So before
we jump into the video, I because I'm a wonderful
person and I want this thing to be as simple
and as understandable as it can be. I went
ahead and was created my starter file so that
we just cut off some unnecessary parts something
that you already know about. Sorry. So this
is the repo I'm going to leave the link to
the repo in the description below so that
you can have access to this repo. So when
it comes to the reporting, there are two branches.
The main branch is going to contain the completed
projects. And when you switch or when you
switch the branches. It says the select over
here you can choose the starter file here
at a startup branch here sorry, when you choose
it. It's the startup branch contains everything
about the continuous data data first neither
for these projects, okay? So just switch there,
then go to code, then you can clone it, or
you can download as a profit and just open
it up inside your favorite text editor or
code editor. I'm going to use Visual Studio
code. Okay, so let me close this stuff to
be no worries again. Alright, so this is the
repo for the project. It has two branches,
the starter branch and the main branch. The
main branch is for the completed projects.
And the starter branch is for the brand that
contains all the Stata files, okay. So we
can meet you come here, you clone it, I have
some templates are for providing some templates
and some static files, which are the images
that we are going to use. Okay. So when you
click on it, you're going to see this something
like this. Sorry, I'm feeling like this. You
have a normal Django project that has been
generated with Django does admin start project
and I gave it a name? Django Netflix. Okay,
so inside the Stata files to add a static
file footer, you see some images and some
styles or CSS or via which was generated with
tailwind CSS, so I've pitched a tailwind CSS
file. So this is x. And inside there? Was
it in the templates, you have some a couple
of templates that has been created for you
already. And I usually I used I used a tailwind
CSS as usual, my favorite CSS framework. Okay.
So this is it. So this is, let me let me talk
about the changes that I've made in the fall
that were generated by the Django design.
So I changed just two files, the settings.py
file and the URLs up UI file right here. So
inside a settings.py file, I changed I added
this inside of there, so the templates, or
the directories or the templates, either the
directory for this template folder over here.
And when you scroll down, you see I've done
some magical ways that we'll be able to use
our static files or be able to hold our static
files. So either the static routes, the media
routes, the media URL, and the static files,
this okay. So because we are going to use
a development server, we are we have to find
a way of saving our media files and an our
static files. So I added the static, either
this line of Codea, which allows us to save
our static and media files whilst we are still
in development. Okay. All right. So these
are just the changes that I've made in the
fog that were generated by the Django dash
admin. Alright. So let's continue. Let's get
into the action of the project. Okay. So the
first thing I want to do is you're going to
create a new app. Okay, you are going to create
a new app, we are going to call it scorso
Python stats. No, sorry. Python managed up
Pui. Oh, what is wrong? My head they get?
Why did your pui start up was the name of
one score the score will get an error somewhere.
Okay, no error today, escalate this. Okay,
so we have created our Oh, our new app over
here. So let's close it. ls move up. And he
said our installed apps. Let's add iterates
is aapko. Right is one. And the next thing
I want to do is you want to add a URL up Wi
Fi here so that we will be able to some way
of make our URLs modular based on the apps
itself. Instead of having all your big directly
inside the main your pure iPhone, okay. All
right. So, let's add a new file here. Call
it URLs Pui. Alright, so inside the ui.py
file, we are going to first import path. Okay,
then the next thing we are going to do is
also have a URL, the URL pattern list. Okay,
so first import. So I thought I'm writing
Java scripts. So from Django, dot URLs, import
path Oh, sorry, no dispatch, yes. This way,
then we are going to have an app name because
we are going to use a namespace inside our
main URL. So App Name is going to be close
to core. Then you have the URL, path and list.
Alright, this is it. We are done with this
for the meantime, let's close it. And inside
the main urls.py file, this one here, the
one that was generated by Django does admin
and the other one that you cloned, you're
going to add, you're going to include Dauda
URLs. So path, and we are going to give it
to the routes. The routes, Route, okay. So
you're going to give it an include. And you're
going to pass it core dot URLs. You with a
namespace, you can see I getting some error.
So you have to import include namespace. The
namespace is going to be close to core. Alright,
so let's import this include include can be
imported from Django dot URLs. All right,
like this. So you can't say if it's now you're
done, okay, so it's basically done with this.
Okay, you're not done with it. So, since you
are done with this thing, the next thing I
want us to look at is our models, okay? So
inside the course, the core folder, open the
model the PI file. Alright. Okay, so first,
you're going to start by creating our own
custom design, because we just want to extend
it a little bit by just adding just one shoe
to it. Okay, so we don't want to change the
authentication system, or anything. It's not
anything special. So we are just going to
use the abstract instead of the abstract basis,
which allows us to create a fully fledged
or fully flexible custom user by just going
to use the abstract user, okay, which just
allows us to just extend the thoughts of the
user which Django provides to us okay. So
from Django dot contrib dot dot dot models.
Import abstracts. I always put so this the
wrong abstracts abstract like this, okay.
So let's go ahead and create our coastal visa
class. I was quite impressed on visa. Don't
get confused with them. And you're going to
hate from the abstract. Sorry, was Autolite
change is so abstract is like this. Alright,
so the only thing that you're trying to add
is trying to give it a profile filled. Alright.
So of profiles and is going to be a many not
a minor. Many to manifold Sorry, sorry sorry
guys sorry. Since my brain is on some overload,
so models, DODDS may need to be ready for
what was going on many too many for just like
this and this is going to be to the profile
profile profiles table okay, they are going
to have Nol equals true and blank equals shoe
like this alright. So, this is it, this is
it. Okay. So, we are done with our ESA The
next thing I want to do or look into is the
profile the profile, the profile model, okay,
so plus profile and we are going to inherit
from models dot model Oh, sorry. Alright.
Alright, so, the profile is going to have
a name, alright, so a profile supposed to
have a name, the profile is going to be the
Netflix profile, okay? The one that usually
creates, too, you can use to watch a movie,
if you are familiar, Netflix, you're supposed
to know that shuffled. So we are going to
use a character food and is going to have
a max length of two to five or key, it's going
to be required. So So and the next one is
going to be an age limit. So we know whether
it's for kids, or as for or so you show them
the appropriate content. Okay. All right.
What's all this was this Alright, sorry, guys.
So that was going to be a mother, it's also
going to be a models dot char field want to
have the max length of them going to be choices.
I'm going to be age and our school choice.
And that's called choices. So let's go and
create the choices still choices are up here
see a
choices going to be caused to a tupple or
a tuple then we're going to have to two food
in it. Okay, so one is going to be for all
and the other is going to be so the first
one is the one that is going to be saved to
the database. And this is the one the one
which is going to be displayed to a user.
Okay. The next one is going to be kits and
kits. Alright. So there's what's going to
be used here and an STI we want here as a
UU ID for this profile. So we are going to
use our models dot u u ID field. Alright,
I are going to set a default for it. Which
is going to be equals to u u ID dots. So let's
first import the UID a UID module from Django,
eight from Python, sorry, and put your ID
Okay, so you ID and there is a version called
UI default. Okay, this one here, I like the
fork. Alright, so you're done with the profile
model. So the UID is going to allow us be
able to request for a particular module or
is going to make it that how do I put it,
differentiate between it. Okay, so class,
the next thing I'm going to board is the movie
class or the movie model. going to show you
guys four models that model then a movie actually
has a title. So let me clean this one day.
It's not a name. So title, then it's going
to be a models dot char field. max length
is going to be equal to two, five. The next
thing I want to have is a description of the
movie. So it's going to be models dot char
field, or no, sorry, we can store the description
that we are going to use a text area, a text
word, sorry, what did I just spell? text text
that tests this vote. Okay, we're going to
set in the blank equals true. And na equals
true. Alright, you're supposed to be capital,
you're not writing JavaScript. This is the
most interesting language and the best framework
ever. created when we created food today,
that is going to be models that date, time
thought are going to add an auto. Now add
because you so this is going to add the date,
the time and the date and time that the movie
The movie class was created to the store,
okay? So we don't need to go and find out
or put in a time ourselves, right? It will
be added for us automatically. Right? So then
so now we want to add or the next food we
want to add is the UU ID field. So that is
also going to make the movie said we're gonna
have to differentiate between the movies Okay,
so models.ui default Okay, so now we are also
going to get down to a default, which is going
to be equal to u ID dot u u ID for alright.
And the next thing that we want to do is add
the type of movie where our editor sees now
movie or it's just just a single movie. Okay,
so as far as I didn't actually want to add
this part, but it's it makes sense. You can
have a Netflix with just only was single movies.
You have to have seasonal movies too. Okay.
Alright, so it makes sense. Safford No, Safford
and the max length this is going to be Ted
and you're going to use choices going to be
close to movie and I score choices Alright,
so let's create the movie choices over here
over here then you're going to have one sees
now like this alright. And sees now sorry
sees now but I suppose Oliver Come on, come
on. Alright, so the next one is going to be
was was the name single thing go and you're
gonna be seeing go alright, So, you're down
to the movie choices. So you're supposed to
be choices this way that we, alright. The
lesson I want to add, as was the name, the
video is to put out a video file or video.
So, let me let me explain to you the database
setup. So you have a movie, a movie, a movie
thought, a movie table that is going to hold
all the movies that are inside the database.
And inside a movie table, a particular instance
are going to have videos, the video can be
just one video, if it is a single, it's a
single movie, or a single type of movie, but
it can hold many instances of the movie. What
was the name? many instances of the movie
model? Okay, so if it's a seasonal movie,
so in a seasonal movie, you have a lot of
movies that are linked to that particular
movie, but if the single movie just has one
movie, okay, I hope it's clear. Right? Then
so we are going to have videos which is going
to be a models that many to many, many to
many many to many thought and this is going
to be related to the video filled. Right.
Okay, then the next thing that is going to
be s is going to be you want a flyer or a
poster for it. So we're going to call it a
flyer. So it's going to be a models dot image
vote and I'm going to choose that it should
be uploaded to upload to where should we upload
it to flyers? Yes. Alright. And we are going
to the every movie is supposed to have an
age limit so that we'll be able to know which
kind of movie to show to each age limit. Okay.
So it's going to be also going to be equals
two models dot char filled and the maxlend
this is the this is going to be 10 and the
choice is going to be choices. Sir choices,
which is the age choices. Alright, okay, okay,
I hope you guys are following me. Alright.
So this is it, you're done with the movie,
the movie model. So let's jump into the video
model where we are going to hold our individual
video or movie file, right? So that is also
going to be models dot model. So is going
to have a name, it can have a title. So let's
say it's an it's a seasonal movie, to the
seasonal movie can have a title that particular
video instance can have a title let's see
episode one, episode two episode three. But
in the in the case of a single video, then
given it the single video instance the title
doesn't make sense. Okay, they are going to
make it a models dot char field you're going
to make it max length of two to five blank
equals true. Black equals true So that's those
scissor movies or the single movies can escape
this field without passing it any value and
gnarly costs true. Alright, then the next
thing that we need is the most important and
the file the video file itself so the data
is going to be a muddles dots. file filled
Okay, so this is it, and you're going to choose
an upload, upload to when to upload it to
movies. Alright. Okay, so guys, we are done
with our database setup. So this is the model
that we are going to use for this projects.
Right? So this is this one here, video, movie
profile and Acosta visa model. Okay, so save
it up, save it up. Okay, so this is the models
done completed. All righty, let's jump into
the views. Okay, so let's start writing some
views and see the magic that we are putting
together. Alright. So in this, this series,
the series in this today are going to use
the class based approach. Okay, so let's first
import from Django dot views. Import view.
Alright, let's try this. Okay, let me clear
away this. This Hanoi COVID I was having to
record it back again. Oh, I miss you guys,
i to the first thing I want to do is you're
going to create an index page, or let's say
the homepage. So let's create a view that
is going to handle that. So we're going to
call it hope. As you you are home. There is
no way by home, no way like home. So it's
going to inherit from the view. Alright, let's
go on. So Zadar creates a sorry, He now gets
is going to just handle get into taking itself
taking requests, and taking some arcs and
quarks, right. Then, when, when I get requests
made to this view here you want to retain
Aranda. Okay, once you return a Render, Render
has to return requests first, then the templates
that we are sending back so inside when you
check the template folder, from the static
file, a starter file that you cloned, you're
going to see this index dot HTML file here.
That is our homepage. Alright. So HTML, so
I was excited to hear mistakes index dot HTML.
Alright. So this is our simple homepage, right?
So let's, what do I want us to do? Let's add
it to our urls.pi file. So that we'll be able
to preview it, not this year, the PI file
is closed. And let's open the URL is a py
file inside the core. The core was it in the
core folder or the core directory. Alright.
So path, we're going to pass in path. And
we're going to give it the root directory.
And we're going to use the home dots as you
because it's a class b Sorry, it's supposed
to be a capital H. From the US view alright,
I this so let's import in home from views
from the views. Import home. Alright. So save
it up. And now let's start our server and
see the errors I have made. By third. Monday's
the poi rants Okay Oh It seems you have started
making mistakes already so inside the model
the Pew if I made a mistake somewhere on line
25 Instead of charcoal I said shot shot what
is wrong with this boy I'm sure you guys got
that already so let's save it and wait for
this server to restart for us our error again
what's wrong with it here in Hawaii Keith
Otto change related what's going on what's
going on okay costume User Model okay so I
know why this is begin to fuck up so inside
because you're using the abstract is I supposed
to provide it inside provide a custom inside
inside the settings that URLs far right so
when you go down go to the bottom part so
let me add some few comments or settings I
know you know I can't spell so you're going
to add an OT EUSA model and this is going
to be a reference to core dots Costco costume
costume is right like this and said hard not
has no effects. So sorry guys. I always made
this mistake so let's take out this now it
can just be blank but knowledge needed for
many to many field Okay, so save it's then
come here and save this one too. Let's go
down and see what is going whether you are
still alive who who I am getting some errors
having said before, what is the what is this?
Okay, so I think I know where there is a one
way road. So let me clear the terminal phase.
And first, let me make some migration Python
manage py make migrations. If I get an error,
I'm going back to school. So Python managed
py migrate. I think this is what's going to
solve our problem Okay, now let's run our
server again Python managed or py runs server.
Server. I was confused that I ran an NPM script
that vitae UI. Okay, so you can see our problems
are solved. Okay, so now let's go and see
whether the view created is working. And you
open a new tab over here. So localhost you
can see I am a level of view. So port 888
is already open. So let's see GT 1000. Let's
open it up. Let's see what happened. Ki n
vi, we have a disaster. So you have the templates
by you can see the styling is not coming through
and the images to or not coming through. So
we have a horrible one over here. Okay, so,
before we do that, let's let's, let's make
some changes. So you can see inside a folder,
the terminal down here, it's making some GET
request to some asset files. It is not having
access to it. Okay. And I know what with our
Eric, I see it made a request to get estado
CSS, which does not exist at where the directory
died looking for its ads. So let's solve that
issue. So, inside that was the name the the
templates directory, I went to create a new
file, I went to quality base dot HTML. Alright.
Let me change this then. Okay, no worries.
Alright, then you can change this then let's,
let's make some small changes over here. So
you can change this to Netflix. And you're
going to add a block over here I want to call
a title. Okay, so let's put some data over
here. Alright, then, the next thing that we
need to add is our, our CSS. So link going
to our CSS. So our CSS is inside the static
was in a static directory over here. So we
have to find a way of bringing our static
files here and seven, eight. Okay, so first,
you're going to load in your root, our static
okay. Alright, so let's use our static over
here. Alright, so this is our static and so
now you'll be able to have access to our style,
the CSS, which is inside the static directory.
Alright. Then the next thing that we need
is what do we need again? Okay, so we are
going to have another block called orders.
So that's if there are any order lines that
are particular to the page you're visiting,
it will be rendered over here. Alright. Okay,
I think that's make sense. Then the next thing
that we need is we need what do we need? What
do we need? Okay? So create another block
called Content. Content, that is where our
call our content are going to go. Alright.
So this is it. I hope this makes sense. Alright.
Okay. So now that we have our base, HTML done,
it's, it's good. Let's say what do we need,
we don't need anything again. So now let's
open our index dot HTML file. And we're going
to make some small changes to it so that it's
be able to use this basic HTML file we have
used and the URL and be able to utilize our
style dot CSS. Alright, so I'm going to clear
this path. Clear the top part here. And first,
you're going to extend extends this dot HTML.
Alright. Then the next thing that we need
to add is we want to load in our static should
I be able to use it okay. Alright, so this
is the title. So let's add our title to it.
Okay, so another block is called a block the
block a score title, so we can call this a
passing in home. So to show Netflix dash home,
okay, so we can take of this. So, the other
link that I was talking about is this particular
link here. This link is to some icon directory.
It's from Alcon ionic On icons, I don't know
how to pronounce it, but it's not all their
pages that are using it. So we are going to
use a block to render a four, deuce page damnit,
it's okay. So we are going to store it inside
that for this or this block we're going to
move this tent up alright. And you're going
to move this whole thing here. This move this
whole thing, this class here, carrots and
bring it to this one over here the base dot
HTML file let's save it then go back then
we can take off this word is to tax and please
the whole contents of the whole contents of
the file or Yeah, of the file inside the contents
contents block All right, so let me copy,
move the whole path down Go
Go Go Go Go down. Go down go down. My laptop
is a little bit slow. So please forgive me
guys. Stay attached now. Okay, so we can end
here. So I the footer part and let's move
it up. Okay, so when you're done, we can clear
this thing off these two ones these two tasks.
Okay, so let's save it. And now let's go back
and when refresh and see what is going to
work we have any errors. Okay, so you can
see you have Netflix homes. I see that home
is now popping up. Alright, so you can see
you have Mr. stylin back again. With our stylists,
what can they gain but we have a problem.
The problem is that our images are not showing
they're supposed to be an image here than
an image here. But they are not showing I
don't know why. But I know why. Because we
are referencing them directly from the folder
and they are not there. So you have to find
a way of loading them from our static okay.
So when you screw up the images file, you're
going to start from this place this year the
static so let's take all the assets here.
Then they're all inside a static file so static
this alright then go down click on this parts
sorry then let's copy this spots make it static
alright so the I seem there are two or three
more down there let's do that quickly. So
when you scroll down this there's this one
there's another one there's another one down
there too. So let's take on just take over
the static and fun day and if you're using
VS code it makes it even easier okay just
highlight this year and type static to this
disease makes it very simple COVID A static
assets again alright, this liquid loves what
I guess the kidspot Yes, this one The last
part was the name static, what they do Okay,
so let's save it now let's well let's refresh
and see what is going to work okay, let's
give it a few seconds so what happened is
okay, so you can see our images are now in
you see we have our face but almost done.
The face is almost done guys if you are new
to the channel please subscribe to the channel
if you are if you are new if you are old please
like the video share with your friends coming
to the session in the comment section below
is really going to help me Okay, explain so
for three out right Okay, so this is it. So
you can see our images are now coming in,
we have our homepage of Netflix, dawn on it.
So let's jump let's let's go on. So when you
look inside when you go to all the templates
that you see that you'll be using the nav
bar almost in order in order this one in all
the templates so it's it's makes sense that
we made this a pashya then we import it in
all we include it in all of our files. Okay,
so let me cut this part off. And inside the
templates here, we are going to create a new
directory called partials. And inside the
partials directory are going to create a new
file called Nava dot HTML. And inside it's
the navbar that I copied or I caught I would
paste over here. No changes directs the same
thing. The only thing that we need to do is
we have to load in static Alright, that will
be able to have access to it. So static is
loaded for each and individual templates.
Alright, so each templates handles its own
static So load let's save it then let's close
it. You can come back and make some changes
later on. Okay, so now let's include it over
here
let's include it I went to include Pasha house
slash Naga. Sorry Nava dot HTML. Alright.
This, this the some space so it stops. Okay.
Now let's go back and refresh and see whether
there are any changes. So this is the original
one without us copying anything now we should
refresh. Same thing, no different weights
less weight a little bit. The same thing,
no difference. No changes. Okay. All right.
Hope you guys are following. Okay, so the
next thing that I want us to do is, let's
talk about the authentication part of things.
Okay, the authentication. So, in this video,
we are going to use all mighty all or so Django.
We are going to Django all auth to handle
our authentication if you don't know what
all is this is all OT. So all OT is an authentication
package that makes authentication in Django,
very simple and very, like the standard it's,
it's, it meets the standards of authentication,
okay. So it gives you access to social authentication
and normal authentication to as well. So you
just pip install Django or OT, or this is
the documentation. I'm going to link leave
the link inside the description below. Okay.
All right, guys. So please do a pip install
of Django or if you have not done it. I've
already done that. So I'm not going to go
through that step again. And now we're going
to To add some changes to the template file,
they need you to have this Django templates,
contest processor dot A dot request. It's
already inside ours already. So if you scroll
up this is it. Maybe I've made some changes
to it, so, but it's needed. So it's already
there. It was provided by the Django does
admin generator. Alright. And then so now
we need so this thing, this thing over here.
So let's copy this over here. Copy this, go
back. This hire live my life. Okay. So, if
you read the comments, I want to know what
each what each individual import does, alright,
pick up this one too. Alright. Then the next
thing that we need to do is sorry. We need
to add or the name inside our static files,
you need to add these two things, these are
essential and the down one based on the social
or today you want to use. Alright. Let me
close. Let me let me minimize this one down
here. Okay. So let's scroll up. Scroll up.
Let's go to installed apps installed up. So
we'll leave a comment here. Okay, third party.
Party apps. Going Live, it's down here. Oh,
it's didn't copy. Sorry, guys. Let's go and
copy the copy, go back. Paste it again. Alright,
so now you have added it. It seems it left
with some one or two stuff and you're done
with it. So you need to add a site ID equals
to one. And inside that you are the Pew IFA,
you add this one. Right, this part. Alright,
so I'm going to copy down a path. And we just
go and type in the site's ID into it. So sites
underscore id go to one. And when you go into
you go into that root URL, the Pew IFA. are
going to add the URL file, the path that I
copied, okay. My face, I need to either come
over here before, then we'll save that. And
let's go back to our settings or py file again.
Alright, so you're going to make some changes
to us our authentication, so all odds provide
us with some, some configuration that we can
make to make authentication so simple and
lovely. Things are making the source for all
odds. Right? So the first thing I'm going
to add is the authentication method. So the
authentication method allows us to choose
which way are you Sasha logging in? They should
log in with their email, or they should log
in with their username or either username
or email. Right. So So accounts authentication
methought and in this our app, or in this
project, you're going to use email I don't
think was the name Netflix's ever waited for
them to log in. So you just want to be sorry,
supposed to be an email. Not email, email.
All right. All right. So then so now we need
to do is Then you want to make email? a required
field. So email accounts, email accounts email
required. Required required what? How do you
spell it? Okay. Required, we're going to set
it through. So you guys, the Python tool,
not the other programming language to write.
Then you're going to set accounts, authentication
accounts, email verification, sorry, account
email verification once set it to non string
on, not Python, okay, and the last two things
that we need to add is account. User Name
required. So that is going to, though all
auto added to require username when a new
besides registration or not anyone to set
it to fall because we don't want users to
pass in email their usernames when they are
registering. Alright, then the last thing
that I want us to do is now related to all
Autobots, it's related to Django itself which
is the login sorry login with the log a new
redirect URL that went to pay me to slash
for the meantime Alright, OCR is goes to sentences
in profile accounts for something like that.
But I want to put you to slash Alright, so
with this done, let's see what our service
to our life okay, let me scroll down and see
what these other disaster Yeah. Okay, okay.
Okay. So it's saying that you need Okay, so
when you look at the Earth's documentation
down here, it's asking for this required this
10 year so the two already has been added
to our install our by the Django crate up
by we need to add this sites, whatever the
contract sites, right, so scroll up. Let's
add it was added to it and save it. Let's
see what ACR server is restarting again. Let's
see where it's going to work. Okay, so you
can see it's working but we have some migration
that we need to make as soon as possible.
So let's add our server clear the terminal
by manage the poi migrate Okay, so it's going
to migrate quickly then we continue with our
lifestyle a few seconds more so now less on
our survey pui pui around server sorry okay
guys. Alright, so now that we have your data
in this so let's refresh Sorry, sorry let's
refresh Okay, so now let's go to our login
path. You can see you have no even added any
routes but you can go to our login you have
a fully login place which you can log in log
out and all that stuff so account slash login.
Let's click there. So you can see we have
a login here you can go to sign up you can
go to I saw some Forgot Password certain way.
Like it is good to sign in a kid. You can
go to sign in Forgot Password, and you can
reset. See to all gives us all these functionalities
baked in. Okay, so the first thing I want
to do is first you want to change this sign
in and sign up was how do I put templates
or how it looks to Cody and you can let our
users uses. Okay? So first thing, we're going
to override these templates, the templates
for the sign in and sign up. Alright. Okay,
so what are we going to do, they're going
to vary the temperature. Okay, so to provide
all US templates, the first thing that you
have to do is that inside your templates directory,
you're going to create a new folder. Sorry,
not a new file, my bad a new folder or a new
directory and quality account. And he said
accounts if you want to overwrite template
templates for logging, I want to create a
new template and call it login. If you want
to override the template for sign up, you're
going to create a new template and call it
sign up. So for us we are going to move this
our templates login into this directory over
here. Alright, so now let's go back again.
So as far as this was the login page, but
I'm going to get a quite a while but still,
it's it's what the explanation so so now you
can see we have a new login and this is it
using my because yeah, but ya know, you see
what they, they base the HTML, that's why
it's not looking beautiful at all. Okay, so
let's make it beautiful. Let's make it beautiful.
So let me close this terminal open the the
templates up and let's make some changes to
it. Alright. Okay guys, so we are going to
make some changes to our our templates so
just like we did for the home view you're
going to clear the spots let's clear this
one off or waiver us so first you're going
to extend extend this path and with this you're
going to go back one directory then go into
get the base dot HTML file because base your
HTML files not directly inside the accounts
for us we are going back there I can have
access to ACA The next thing you're going
to have is the block the block title by Dale
in here is going to be login so we can clear
off this one here is two tents over here we're
going to have another block code or this Okay,
let's move this script up into the block like
this. Okay, so we're going to do is you're
going to surround the main content or the
the content inside the body tag in a block
content block content tag okay. So content
so content or what am I spelling alright if
you can't hire me at that place, please contact
me oh guys. Well let's place is a very it's
what did I fries, I really enjoy the application.
Okay, so this is it. So let's go back and
refresh and see whether you're going to have
some something. So let's refresh. I hope we
don't get any error. Give it a few seconds,
a few seconds. Okay, so you can see you have
some pain going on. First, our logo is not
coming in and we are supposed to have some
background image. It's also coming in. So
let's go and fix that. So I told you that
we are going to use our navbar So we can include
it also here. So let's take our to this now
back, then let's include it include it's going
to go backwards, then go into our past years,
slash navbar dot HTML. No, it's this. Okay,
so the next thing I need is this thing here.
The background image, let's change this to
reference from our static so this copy of
static like this. Alright, so it seemed us
or our you need is our law, we need all we
need. Let's refresh it again, and see whether
you get an error, I knew you're going to get
an error because you didn't load in our static.
Let's go back. So let's load in static Okay,
with that done, let's go back and refresh
the flesh. Okay, since we didn't get any error
again in ways it's Fula, you can see our was
in it. And now it's showing here, and our
background imagery showing the beautiful beautiful.
As you can see, I did a good work with the
stylet. Okay, guys. So one thing that you
have to take into consideration is that the
names here should match the name and idea
for the individual inputs should match the
one which would have been provided for you
if you're using the original templates provided
by was in all odds. Okay, so here, we need
to make here login. So the name is supposed
to be sorry. It's supposed to be a was login
and ID login. Okay. Sorry, I should have done
this earlier on. Okay, let's see, what's the
lesson that I want us to check is this where
we are going to render our error messages
if there's any errors with the email in which
the authentication credential has been provided,
okay. Okay, guys, so for us to be able to
enter the arrows here. I'm going to paste
in some code shortly. So this is it. So let's
just take out this static static error that
I provided just to so I stopped with a styling.
Okay, so I think the code I pasted was from
here to here. Okay. So let's, so this is going
to check if the form has arrows. If it has
an arrow, it's going to create this div, and
it is going to render their forms dots, non
filled arrows. Okay. This is it. Alright.
So, the next thing that I want us to do is
let's say a person is on the homepage, or
let's say is watching a particular movie and
want to go to the login, I want us to the
user to be redirected back to the please are
they where they logged in from? Okay. The
loading forms, they are going to add in some
snippet of code to us Whoa, inside the form.
Let me pull it over here below this. So I
have it already copied to my clipboard. So
this is it. I think that's it. paste it over
here. This is this. Okay. So let me scoot
over here. elektrobit, soy, KC composites
and enter in Destin, so it redirects the person
back to where they clicked the logged in from
alright. So civets. Let's go back and test
it again. Alright, so let's try. Let's try
logging in. So let me see my favorites, you
know? Okay, so we can see nothing happen,
it is because of something that I know about.
I'm guilty about it. So inside the form on
the form tag, you're supposed to specify which
method that we want to use. So at the meantime
it is using get, which is not the right way.
So it's supposed to be the method is supposed
to be set to post. Right? So let's go back
and refresh again. Let's click on this then
from there, refresh. And I know you're going
to get that error. So let me not because make
that error phase. So inside Django for us
to submit a form is supposed to have a CSRF
token, okay, for security reasons. So we are
going to add a CSRF token to it. We are going
to get an error. Let me refresh again. Alright.
So admin. And the super strong password admin.
Let's post let's let's log in and see what
is going to happen what is going on what is
going on? You can see, now we have an error.
This is a dynamic error that is coming in
from the back end says the email or password
he specified is not correct. Okay, so something
is going on over there. So the next thing
let's go and work on the sign up as well to
kind of sign up. So the first thing that I
want us to change is basically before we go
and continue that, I want us to route this
link to the signup page. Okay, so let's add
a URL here. So as a URL, URL and is going
to go to sign up, sign up. This L sign up
we will be serious. Okay. This is it. This
is it. Now let's go back and refresh. Let's
refresh it again. It saying it does not exist.
What is this? Okay, let's go back. Let's go
back. Sign up. Excuse me. Okay, guys, so it's
apparently supposed to be account underscore
sign up. Right? There it's okay, so no errors,
errors, no errors, no errors, images also
coming in so you can see when you open it
and I send into account slash, whatever, whatever.
So let's click on let's see what I see we
are now on our sign up. Now. Let's go back
on the signup templates in Alright, so inside
this the same thing that we did for the login,
they're supposed to have a file that is called
sign up inside this account file over here.
So they've been a wonderful person and the
official Django Papa, I am moving this for
that I further provided for inside this data
file inside this account folder. Alright so
now let's go refresh it and see whether I
want to get take note of what you're seeing
here is going to be different because mine
is also going to be cloudy. Okay, so I see
my into my hustle logo and other stuff over
here. So let's, let's go and make some changes
to it so that he uses the base your HTML file
and that assets fast. Alright. So let's take
out the spots Let's stand This so you have
to move back that are actually based HTML
then the next thing is less load in our static
before we make any error is not as big as
the Lord yes God wants to play it's my brain
Okay the next thing we need is the block the
title and the title is going to be oh shit
nada Okay, going to be not saying sign up
sign up right day the next thing I need is
another block that is going to be called block
on block or this let's move this into it as
they call this parts
what are we going to call it we've got the
price blockquote there let's move over this
thing insert like this allistic of this to
here. Alright, so the next thing that we need
to add as the background is bigger than the
stick of this assets areas for reference this
fall was static Alright, the next thing that
we need to add as I want us to change this
redirect CSI sends us to the sign at the login
page. Okay, you're under sign up so you have
to go back to the login. So you are to go
to Accounts underscore login save it now let's
go back and refresh Okay, so can see have
something now you have something here. Okay,
but now it's no less important. Sorry, I forgot
about that. Let's take all this then and included
include our navbar from the partial include
partials. So supposed to be a string first
you have to move back partials slash nav bar
dot HTML save it go back refresh wait for
a few seconds a few seconds what that is it's
so our sign up page also can be very fully
Beautiful, beautiful. Or so one or two changes
then we are almost done at this place. So
just as the other one here is the names and
this one should be the same. So here is supposed
to be password one the name suppose the password
one ID password one, something like that.
Yes, I think this is to do the right one.
And you also want to Renda was the name our
our arrows, okay, arrows, instead of having
a statically typed over here. whereas it,
this is it and we take it out and the code
that I pasted in from the previous code, I'm
going to paste it again. Same thing so you
can pause it and type it in. Okay. All right.
Then the final thing is the redirect the redirect
and then alright. The Okay, let's put it let's
put it here. Let me get it for my PC over
here. Scoot over here. You can see scroll
scroll. Righty righty. So I think that is
all that is that I wanted as far as that is
concerned. All right. So and the last thing
the last bit obviously the last thing let's
add our CSRF token using a form so CSRF token
let's change this method from get to post
to method is going to be post alright so now
let's refresh Alright, so you can see this
beautiful Tenova so let's try log in and see
where they are going to get any errors. So
that is my second favorite password in though
let's click on log in they're going to be
errors a few seconds small and wonderfully
we didn't get any errors okay, because you're
not supposed to be rendering this error server
here because this is the signup form it's
not giving us was the name the non fraud errors
it is giving us a field errors Okay, so you
have to use those ones okay. So instead of
using this one over here, let's take out or
this one today sorry about that guys. Use
this one instead. Let me push this thing backwards
a little or some you will Alright, it is the
arrow they are going to use so let's refresh
the illustrate again I'm using a very short
sponsor sir we get an arrow to test whether
their functionality is working okay, so you
can see now that there is a camiseta password
is very is too short, it must contain whatever
whatever. So yes, you can see it's working
so let's create a pass let's create a new
account let's use a better password so let's
see tests 1234 super strong password test
1234 Key Let's load a sign up and see whether
it's gonna work can't see the password to
is very common. So which was what I was going
to say again? Okay, let's let's cisgendered
up I'm going to use color cast as my password
though I don't think it's going to camo kill
artists. And it's also above it's Kyla test.
Let's log in and see a sign up and she's gonna
work. Okay, so you can see we are successfully
signed up. Then you have also been redirected
to our what's the name? The login homepage,
alright. Okay, so you can see there's it So
let's go back. And inside our navbar dot HTML
file, I want us to do some quick changes,
some PHP code changes, alright. So you're
going to add another button. But we want to
show sign in if the person is not logged in
and sign out if the person is already logged
in. So if request.user.is authenticated and
not made out over here with an error so the.is
supposed to be just simple. That is authenticated,
they want to show this one over here
or else you want to show another one that
is similar to this one by one to log out,
so sign out instead that change it, logout.
So if a user is logged in, we want to show
logout. That's the other way around. So let's
move this one down Alright, so now let's refresh
and see whether it's gonna work. So you can
see because you have signed in, sign up and
sign us in, that's why you're seeing the logged
in. Okay, so let's work on the Logout functionality
quickly. Okay, okay, so for us to handle the
logout, you have to send a push your cache
to the back end, which is going to handle
that for us to make a post request, we also
need a form. Even though all AWS provides
a way of signing out on a get request, which
will just make a request to the endpoints
and to send a person out, it is not advisable
to sign out a user using a get request. You
can find more about it inside Django documentation.
Okay, so get request is not made to make changes
on a resource on the server. But a post request
is supposed to do that. So it's more advisable
to use a post request. So first, you're going
to create a form over here. For me the method
of post the action is going to be handled
by self Okay, so I'm going to have your posts
and you're going to move this button inside
it okay now we're going to change the type
Okay, the type is already solved mistoria
by the type. So they're going to change the
action, the action, the action, good action.
And I want to pass it the URL to account account
underscore logout. Okay. So, guys, you need
to change this. Make it small. Sorry, sorry,
sorry, sorry about this. This way. Alright.
Make sense? Then need to provide a CSRF token
because you're using a formos jiankou Cry
CSRF token. I think that is it. Let's save
it. Then go back. Let's refresh it. See whether
we're going to have any arrows. Okay? So let's
log out what's happened? You see we are logged
out. So we can sign in again. Alright, so
the Logout functionality is working. So guys,
you're almost done with the authentication
part of this project. Let's click OK. So let's
make this thing go to the world in the sign
up page, which is it makes more sense. So
down here, the button that goes to we're going
to wrap it with an h ref dot points two points
to the URL of the login is going to be account
underscore login Okay, so let's move this
whole PWA towards, let's say, let's go back
then refresh, refreshing. Okay, so give it
a few seconds. My computer doesn't blows up.
Guess click on it. Let's see where it says
us. And voila sends us to login. So we can
log in and see whether it's going to work.
The account that I recreated was was the name
B b.com. And the password was killer test.
Let's see whether I wanted to get logged in.
Okay, so it seems we have logged in, you're
able to log in successfully. No errors now.
Okay, so you can see our logout button over
there. Okay, for some reason, since my was
the fonts are not working, because there's
not a font I used let me fix that in them
check why that's okay, guys. So I think I
know why that why the fonts are no working.
I know looking grades. So inside the base
dot HTML file. By its without guy, this guy.
You need to add one class today to this thing
here. Add font and a score. A font does primary.
The primary Yes, fonts, just font that's primary.
And also below the block here. Add in the
scripts. This small JavaScript. I don't want
to scare anyone. So this module received you're
going to need it later. Okay, so just put
it in for the meantime. Okay, let's save it.
Let's go back and refresh and see whether
it's going to look a little bit nicer and
close out there. All that flex on page okay,
I have a weird What's this? Okay, so now that's
loaded in the fonts and it looks more beautiful.
Beautiful, beautiful. Nice one. Nice one.
Okay. So the next thing I want to do work
on as the profile page, or yes, the, the,
the view that is going to show us our profiles.
Alright. So let's go back to Visual Studio
code. Okay, guys, so let's jump into the views
and right. The view for our was their profile
page. Okay, so we can close this base html
index dot HTML to kind of go sign up and log
log into Congo down Sign up Okay, so now let's
go back to our views py file so, I'm going
to create another view so we're going to call
this class class, the class profile list with
us where we are going to list our profiles.
So it's going to say heritage heritage view
Sorry, sorry guys, then the next thing we
need to get is the the Deaf gets defined our
gets method. So self with digging, so for
quests, arcs, and quarks. Then the next thing
I want to get is the profiles. So profiles,
the profiles of that our our current user,
okay, ie serratus, assessing the, the current
the profile page so so you're going to get
it from the request dot user dot profiles
that is the folder we just added to our custom
user then because it since it's a many to
many field, we can call that dot all on its
we get all the fields, or the A profiles and
you're going to return render render of our
requests and was the name their templates
name is going to be profile less dot HTML.
So when you check the templates, which you
cloned, you see a profile as it's okay, now
we're going to pass some contexts arguments
along so, we are going to pass a contest called
profiles. So profiles are my What am I spell
if you can spell profiles, okay. I wish it
was JavaScript where you just type profiles
that are going to do the magic for you. So,
yeah, referencing this profile, okay. So,
this is it, this is the view that is going
to give us our profile list. But the problem
is that if a person that is no sign in try
to assess this this endpoint or this view,
we are going to get an error because that
person is going to be an anonymous user. And
anonymous user instance does not have this
profile instance on its profiles instance
or the post profile photos on it sorry guys,
okay. So we have to protect this routes. So
we have to make it open to only sign in users
are logged in users okay. So from Django sorry,
supposed to be Django Django dot contrib contrib
dot decorators want to import the login required?
So with the login required decorator alright.
Okay, so since you are using a class based
view, we can't directly decorate this this
view. So, we are going to use the method created
to this to decorate the dispatch. The dispatch
method, okay. So I'm going to pull down to
from Django dot contrib a dot util sorry.
utils dot decorators imports method okay with
a decorator like this
I essentially want to decrease the dispatch
are going to place a decorator here so the
art symbol you're going to use method the
Creator right and the creator is the login
the Creator login required decorator and the
name of the method I want to create is the
dispatch sheet so the service now we should
provide a path or route for this view so let's
go to our urls.py file inside the core directory
then let's import profile list they go to
patch and they are going to provide it this
sorry profile oh what's wrong? Okay. Then
I'm going to provide a profile less dots as
you Okay, hope you guys are following then
the name they're going to give us too far
and our score list Okay, so see every day
I leave right I guess so there's no arrow
or there's an arrow for this there's no highlighted
and that is a vital alive key the server is
still alive let's go to the endpoint and see
whether it's going to work slash profile and
you can see we are logged in okay slash profile
and you can see we have some 10 bucks it's
not looking great so let's let's work on that
template quickly. So let's go to profile list
profile list no one is going to very simple
quick quick quick quick. Since you have seen
it already it is going to extend
be stored HTML or another block a block title
once a goddess prefer a stick of this one
see goddess block content smooth this whole
thing go down go down there's no discretion
move this thing up. Okay, let's take these
two then let's take our this nav bar and include
include the one form partials slash nav By
now go to HTML. Okay, save it. Then let's
go back and refresh. See what happens. Okay,
okay, so you can see you have something going
on over here. Something going on. Beautiful,
beautiful, beautiful. Alright. So this once
this there's a static depth, I want to take
those loose ones off and are going to look
over the ones that we are going to break.
Okay? Let's stick is this just going to live
just one okay this one alright, thank you
I went to run a for loop okay. So for for
profile
in profiles this
okay write this and you want to make this
10 on each on a tag. Okay, so now we'll be
able to, for the meantime, I want to make
it a hash for the meantime. Okay. So when
you click on the diff, it's going to send
us to is going to allow us to use that particular
profile. Okay. Right. So I want you to add
in this template or this small HTML inside
this div. Yeah. This thing over here, so we
get the profile name, then it slides itself,
we just have just one letter, and below a
to replace the was the name. The profile name,
the profile name. So we have like if it's
the profile name is altered, they are going
to have a capital or a big one and below 80
are going to have a trade there below it.
Okay, so let's add this few plus flex Fluss
dash call. That's going to be with Flex column
and justify the center align center right
center, right this right? And save it. Let's
go back again. Let's refresh what you're going
to see you want to like it? Because there
won't be anything over here. Okay, yes, because
our user doesn't have any profile yet. That's
why it's not showing anything currently. Alright.
So let's go back. So we are going to log out
over here and see what's going to happen whether
you're going to see this page or it's going
to pick out from this page she's picked us
back to the login page, or T. Okay, that's
nice. So let's try since you are logged us,
let's try going to the profile profile page
again. profile like this should I go into
the route again. And because we need to log
in before we need to be logged in or the name
to be logged in before you have access to
that page or the view. It has brought us to
the login page. Okay, so let's log in and
see whether we can go there now be okay, this
person, killer, killer test voila, we are
redirected to our page our homepage alright.
So the next thing I want to hit on is creating
a new profile so that if a user comes in has
no profile that him or her can go to the profile
page. Okay. But before we do that, I want
us to Add some changes to the view. So, to
the home view, so if a user is logged in already,
you want that person not to see the index
page, but whenever he tries to access the
home pages, you send him to the profile page.
Okay? Now it makes more sense because what
is already on the homepage is not is not something
that's should be shown to someone that is
already logged in. Alright. So if request,
the user is authenticated. Thank you I supposed
to request not request then you're going to
return a redirect. Okay, so I'm going to click
on it. She's going to auto import redirects,
redirects for me, okay. So you have to add
it to your imports. Okay, so you want to be
redirected to call hyphen is no hyphens semi
colon trufa Refer underscore list. Okay, so
this year I'm using reverse reverse URL. Okay,
so let's save it and since you are logged
in user let's try accessing the homepage as
to accessing the homepage which is less fees
Okay, since you have some crazy errors down
what's what's wrong? Oh, sorry, it's supposed
to be 1000 So you guys got stats. Let's try
refreshing. Since you are logged in see it
redirects us to the profile page. Beautiful
beautiful beautiful. Alright guys, so let's
go and work on the profile creates Okay guys,
so let's create let's work on their profile
creates view so let's go down so it's always
going to be class for for grades Okay, is
going to inherit from view Okay, so you're
going to have a get method now we're going
to take in solve requests they can add some
cracks okay then inside the get request, you
want to return a form that form is going to
help us create the profile here. So let's
say I want to have let's just leave a comment
form for adding no for creating creating a
profile write the lecture 10 render everything
or enough to render the request and retain
the the profile creates HTML Alright, so let's
save it there let's go and add it to the URL
so first, let's import it in lesson 45 grids
so yeah, supposed to be a capital. Okay. fuckwits
like this they are going to use a pack when
to send it to Foofa slash greets slash then
you're going to the profile create greet.as
view was set like this you so the name is
going to be five grids as you just guessed
Alright, Alrighty, so let's go and test it
out let's check let's first check rasa life
our key is to arrive there's been tested out
profile slash greets it saw so you can see
we have something over here so you have to
get an edit our our was what the code our
templates so templates right where this profile
create screw this terminado so first you're
going to do the usual stuff let's pick our
distance distance stance base dot HTML then
we need another blog title I'm going to call
it live that test proofer greets supposed
to be capita profile as looks nice let's take
our this the stocks they call this one two.
Okay. Then I have another block here called
block content contents Alright, so let's grab
everything inside
it inside a section, the last section of this
last two talks send it into the block content
take out these two. Okay so now we have to
take out this now didn't include our our naff
Pasha last year last Naga HTML okay now civets
is going through okay, something is coming
through since you're supposed to be an image
behind it. Okay, does my screen look thing
that I supposed to look I feel like there's
supposed to be an image behind it. So let's
just add an image. This is image as a background
file. Okay. So let's first load static
in the section here, let's add an inline style
that is going to take an aboveground. Now
down to its image that is going to be a URL
to static and you're going to use background
or go Under gap let me check your static files
so I've done this beforehand my laptop is
freaking slow background underscore Netflix
dot jpg lists dot jpg, jpg Okay and here let's
add the classes lead at BG dash Koga. Alright,
let's refresh and see how you want to look
like alright, this one looks more beautiful.
Nice it's a nice one. Okay, so the next thing
you're going to do is you're going to work
on the form on the form that you're going
to use to create the the profile okay so inside
our, our core directory, create a new file
call from the UI from the poi Alright alright,
so yeah, we're going to import one or two
stuff so from Django not Django. What did
I saw Django that forms Oh, this forms import
model form alright and we are going to import
our model to the form dot model imports profile
that's what you're going to use scores Yeah,
supposed to be dot models Okay, so you're
going to create a class called profile for
if I can spell to follow through a file Form
which is going to inherit from the models
the model form I guess, then we're going to
give it a class meta sorry. Sorry about this
combined thing is supposed to be class meta.
And below are going to specify the model with
a transfer method model is going to be equal
to the profile model that we just brought
in. Then you are going to specify an exclude
Okay, now the folder should be excluded and
the folder we want to exclude is the UU ID
field surah the UID is generated dynamically
from the back end alright. Don't worry about
that. You don't have to worry about that.
Okay. So now we are done with our the form
for creating our profile. So let's import
it in and use it here inside our view Okay,
so first let's import it in from was the name
from dot forms import profile form and proof
of imports profile form Okay, so now we have
our profile form here. So the next thing I
want to do is we want to use our profile form.
So from I'm going to create an instance of
form of that profile form. So, profile form
then instantiate it. And I'm going to pass
it along a path along inside as a contest
argument, right Alright, I hope it makes sense.
Alright. So this is it. This is our formula.
So this one is just the gets Metro so it doesn't
make any doesn't make much changes, most of
the functionality is going to be inside the
POST method. Okay, so let's save it. And as
we make some changes inside our creates templates.
So you're supposed to have two fields, one,
which is going to be a select and the other
which is going to be so an input for the input
for is going to take in the name. So here
is supposed to be just name, a profile name.
So the name here, you see I've been changing
the name and the ID name. So the name here
should correspond to the field name, the name
that was given to the phone, and the ID should
be ID underscore the full name, you get it.
Alright, so here is going to be ID underscore
name like this, and here is going to be ID
underscore age limits. If you check the model
you'll see that that's how they are called
age limits, H underscore limits this is going
to be ah underscore limits right this right,
this is it's okay, now let's add our method
today to the form which is going to be a post
there let's add our CSRF token. Right, this
is it, this is it. Okay, we are going so let's
we can close this thing here. Let's close
it down, then the form there let's go back
to our view again. So with a get method we
are we are done with it, you don't have anything
to do with it. So the next one we're going
to focus on is now the posts method. We're
going to have a def post which is going to
take in so requests and acts and quacks. Axiom
cracks, then you're going to create the form
instance again, another form instance of the
profile, not mine oh sorry. So far form. But
this time around, you're going to take in
the request POST request dot post, or none.
This is going to help I'll get to the data
that has been posted from the front end here.
So that is going to be stored is that a request
dot post or none? All right. That means if
there is nothing inside it, that's what is
going to be done right or if there is nothing
like a post, there is no post right. So first
I want to check if the form is valid. If the
form is valid form underscore valid. If I
spell valid then if it is valid, we want to
watch less first sprint, the sprint form dots,
clean data that is going to give us the values
of the form or right from the screen data
When you're done, you want to return a render,
as usual. So Django cried today return a render
or a redirect, you have to return a response
does what I want to see an empty, you have
to return a response. So our response is going
to be a render, you're basically going to
do the same thing as this. Let me just copy
it to save some time by this so save it. Let's
go back to the form. And let's refresh this
thing. So let's pass it in in Lesbos, ultra
def. In the maturity level, want it to be
all, then let's send a post. Okay, so the
post has been done, let's go and check inside
our terminal whether the values were so you
can see the values came in, this is it. So
the form was valid, and it's printed Declan
data, so you can see the name here and the
age limit here as for? Okay, so since we have
those values, we can now go ahead and create
a profile now. Okay, so instead of just printing,
it's let me just comment, so you have it.
So you can go to Profile. So I'm going to
create a new profile instance. Okay. So I
will just auto import it. So you can see that
imported up here for me. Okay, so you have
to import it in, if you're not using Visual
Studio code. So you don't have to Tao auto
import feature, then you're going to do objects,
objects, dots grids. And you are going to
spread the value that you're going to get
from the the value that you're going to get
from the clean data. Okay, so let's copy this
in here. Let's just start with let's not,
let's not be lazy. So we are going to spread
it so because the dictionary used to asterisk
creates so supposed to be theory, this theory.
So instead of the so what's the we do not
theory, okay, just to get through. So we're
going to spread for four dots clean I need
to go back to some spelling school or something
like that, um, does clean data like this,
all right. But you're going to store the provided
is going to be created inside a variable called
profile. Okay, so when we have this profile
like this, that has been created for us. So
if it's, it's able to successfully create
the profile, then we want to watch redirects
the, the ESA to the place where they're going
to choose they're going to choose what login
to their profile, okay? So if profiles are
checking if their profile was created, and
just not known, if prefer are going to return
a redirect so in redirects anonymous organisasi
I suppose redirect them to the place that
you watch the movie streets, but because you
have not yet created it, you're going to first
redirect them to the profile page, where you
choose your profile okay. So profile. So what
was the way I read it in them is call us in
reverse you are also proof profound as for
list, okay. So this way I read it in them
too. But one thing that we skipped it was
that before somebody will be able to go to
the place where they created a profile that
person is supposed to log in. So we are going
to do the same thing as we did for the profile
list. We are going to protect our out like
this, else, if a user that has no sign in
comes into creates a new profile, there will
be danger. There'll be a big problem. Okay,
so now the profile has been created. Now the
profile has been created here any redirection
if the profile has been created, but this
profile is created, and it is not associated
with any new site. So for us to be able to
associate it with the ESA, we are going to
get inside here, before we do the redirects,
you're going to get to the request dot user.
Then we check the profiles we get to the profiles
here. Then we add to rate because the men
too many filled us at add, okay, we're going
to add def profile to it. Or else it will
just be a disclaimer to not be related to
the user. Okay. Editor, it's beautiful. There
now you can save it when tested out. Okay,
so it seems everything is fine and preference.
So first, let's refresh the decision or key.
So what let's create for Archer def, like
this, and the maturity is also that a con
this submits, let's see what's going to happen.
Okay, so you see I've been brought to our
homepage, go to the profile place profile
page where we can select a profile by since
you have some weird styling. Let's fix that
quickly. It looks too ugly. Okay, so where
did he go wrong? So so so so so justify saying
that airline Center is a Texan TNC what is
going to happen? I don't know why that's happening.
But we'll find out very soon. Okay, so that
was it. So just add a text center. To here
then is going to work then look beautiful
now. So at first there were no too far here.
But now you can see there's a profile here.
So now let's we are going to work on clicking
on the profile and it's sending us to the
to the watch view, okay, where we can select
a movie and watch it okay. Okay, guys, so
now you're able to create profiles and now
display them here. But we left out to Encinia
we didn't link up the URL that helps us to
create the profile to this button here. So
let's do that quickly. So inside a profile
list, HTML dot HTML come into this div Yeah,
then let's surround the bottom which I'm Uncle
and Uncle frog not as willing to have this
as some space in between it and let's move
the button into it this movie then, let's
use our URL so I think it is cool. Dots. Pay
column creates a profile create sorry guys.
Profile underscore creates. Okay, so let's
save it. Let's go back and refresh. Okay,
so let's refresh. Okay, so now since there's
something wrong somewhere, looking so that's
nice that it's working. Okay, okay, so it's
working. It's working. It's working perfectly.
So let's go back So you're done with the profile
listeria. So now what you want to do is that
when a user comes to this profile list and
he or she chooses a profile I should send
them to the page that is going to list all
the movie for them to choose the movie in
which rich they want to watch OK, so let's
work on that. So that one is going to be our
movie list. It's going to be like a movie
list view or something like that. Okay. So
let's go let's jump into our views or py file
close this to here is to false them please
this one to get a basically data so you can
move to the bottom and
create create our new class based views so
we are going to call it our plus or not or
this sorry guys supposed to be at last class
watch Oh, supposed to be a copy probably better
be okay. And you're going to inherit the view
then we're going to define a get a delegate
a get method and we're taking self requests
will be taking profile ID that is going to
be the ID of the profile that was created.
Okay, all the profile was selected, okay?
To be right. Okay, then the next thing that
you want is axiom quarks, okay. Okay, alright.
So now and then what you're going to do within
a nested and nested Okay, so spudding for
that. So we are going to try going to use
a try catch statement right Alright, so let's
get into this so I said try catch try SF State
rates, JavaScript has flooded my brain. So
they're going to try and get the profile,
the profile, which is the profile ID that
was provided, okay. So don't use profile dot
objects dot states. So, we are using a try
accept cards because if this profile does
not exist, it is going to true does not exist
error. So that's why using the track try accept
block so that we'll be able to handle the
arrows will okay. So we are going to get into
the UU ID Okay, the UID is going to correspond
to our profile. Id like this. Okay, cool.
So now we have our our profile okay, you have
our profile. So what you want to do is you
want to gather all the movies from the database
alright. So to be movies What am I spelling
My computer is freaking slow movie begins
gets paid Sorry About Us guys. Okay, what's
happening? Okay guys, so supposed to be movies.
So as you can see the shutter I'm going to
just to to come out with this video. Okay,
so please, if you're new to the channel, please
kindly subscribe to the channel. If you aren't
already subscribed, please. Like the video
key, please. I really cherish it. Okay, so
we are going to FOTA the movies that already
exists inside the database. And I want to
filter with the age limit, so that we don't
provide if the accounts or the profile is
A kid's profile, we don't send it out movies,
okay? So we are going to filter with the,
the order name, the profile, age limits, okay,
so we're going to get it from the profile.
So if you remember, the proofer has age limits
on it. And we are going to use the one to
pass filter. So we are going to get the age
underscore limits. Right this then, when you're
done, we're going to do check for one thing,
that if Okay, so now we have a profile, but
we don't know whether the profile belongs
to the particular user that is currently assessing
it. So we want to check if their profile is
inside the Karen, she says are the abuser
that is assessing now, that page list of profiles,
okay, so we are going to check that. So say
if profile not in request, dot user dots to
file files, that's all okay. If it is not
in it, then we want to cause every redirect
was a redirect and you're going to send a
redirect to I'm going to send a redirect to
call what's a colon fufa underscore list?
That is where the list of profiles are at
okay. But if it is in its or willing to return
a render that has our request sorry, guys
requests request and pass is going to use
the movie list templates that's already made
prepared for you. And you're going to pass
along it's us it's with a contest with a contest
dictionary, which is going to have our movies
Okay. All right. Movies, what it means to
have so hence you're going to reference these
movies over here. Alright. So, but if there's
an error or let's see, if you are not able
to find a profile which is the probable error
that can that can happen. So, profile the
profile model has this does not exist does
not exist error on it. So we can use now another
exception, okay? Does Not Exist does not exist.
So, if it does not exist, we also want to
do the same thing as this one to a 10 day
insert to the profile, the profile list Alright,
so, let's save it up. Then. Let's go back.
SQL Server store still running. Alright. Alright,
it's still alive. So now you have our view
here. So let's add it to our our urls py file
Okay, so it's going to be a path that is going
to have watch and it's going to take in a
string, not as output form, underscore ID.
Okay, so the act that you provided for the
view should correspond to the name that you
provide over here, okay? So I call its profile
ID, that's why it's, it's being called profile
IDs over here. Okay, so when you're going
to use the watch when to the watch, you're
going to call that as you on the model of
on the view, you're going to give it a name
of watch. Okay, so you have to import it here
as yours, you're going to land in an arrow
watch okay so we can save it up. But before
we go and test it out, there's one thing that
we missed out, you're supposed to protect
the view from for only logged in users alone.
So I'm going to copy this, this decorator
over here
copy this, then send it down this laptop of
buy his way yet. That's what I have to out
to make the video. So you guys still. So let's
save it up. And let's go and check it out.
But there's no way of us sending this profile
or linking this profile to the view that we
just created. So let's go and make some slight
changes inside the profile list, VA templates.
So ways that profile is templates to far less
than the guy okay, so the change that I want
us to make is I'm going to add a URL here,
that is going to redirect us to the profile
page to the watch page. Okay. So let's add
a URL here. It is going to use or call on
watch and are going to pass
the profile ID as the profile.uu ID. Okay,
the profile here is the current profile, we
are looping over the currents of data we have
from this profile he profiles list. Okay.
I hope it's clear. So let's save it up. And
let's go back and refresh. Okay, so now when
you open this No, so you can see. Now we have
a watch. If you look down here, let's let's
just click on it and go to that page. So now
you can see now you are able to be redirected
to a new page by seeing if you have an arrow
takes in one argument, whatever, whatever
whatever. So it seems you made an arrow somewhere.
So what happened? So let's take our URL. It's
called profile ID profile underscore ID. So
let's check our view. So that does the what
I was talking about. It's from there always
from now please. spoofer underscore ID so
happened says or takes one positional argument
or two was given. Give it give it the two
I'm ready to begin to get paid Well, where
did this error coming from? I know my not
gonna become incredibly slow. I can't even
check, check, check, check, check, check.
Oh, my bad. Sorry about that. I'm sure you
guys got that. I'm supposed to instantiate
it so now let's refresh this thing again.
Okay, so now you can see, we have some templates
in arrows over here. So let's it's working
just the template has to be fixed. Okay, so
let's go into the what's the profile as you're
done with the profile is started down Okay,
guys, so open up the movie less than plates.
So I think it is to be a good idea if we work
on the template for the three last ones left
is going to be the movie detail, the movie
list and the show movie. Okay, that's us.
Let's work on those three, then we'll get
back into our view again. It's not supposed
to keep longer than that. So we'll finish
that quickly Okay, so this is a show movie.
So let's start with the show movie. Let's
start by taking out the distance of tickets
it's now let's stand at a stand base dot HTML
they are going to have another blog below
that is going to be called Title we're going
to have movie this okay so you can take out
this one these two over here then you're going
to have another block we're going to call
this or this I are going to move in this too
is to interrupt alright the last thing we're
going to do is the block content okay. So,
now we can take away was this can take away
this parts the inclusion of the navbar so
from the navbar to the head like this and
take away the bottom parts as to tax they
are going to move the main into their contents
the blog content and are going to include
include the navbar. Route from partials dot
navbar dot HTML Let me save it. Okay. So I
think we are done with the show, show movie.
So you can close down under if you can, you
can even do it quickly yourself but I just
want to do it quickly so that we just take
our houses or you just view it now views and
focusing on better stuff. Okay, so let's delete
this I'm going to extend this that is HTML
okay, then the next thing we need is a blog
title the same is your stuff
going to placing detail page a stick of this
tool over here
another block let's call it all this winter
move for this scripts dive into it alright
the final thing I'm going to have is the block
contents and the nav bar. So let's lay the
nav bar away with today head tag and whatever
whatever the body tag okay I'm going to have
a block content Okay, so we are going to move
everything inside this let me This is all
I want let's move it into it Alright, so everything
we need to Destin has been already copied
and added to our base html file so we don't
even need to again come close it can delete
it right the nice one so yeah dammit I want
to close its bow you'll be making some changes
when we get there so don't worry no worry
about those ones those changes so change okay,
it is right after this video VGA Oh guys,
so the last changes you need to make so let's
delete this one extend these with HTML no
then you're going to have another block that's
going to be called Title we're going to our
minutes enjoy Netflix enjoy Netflix alright
this let me get away this leg and let's have
a block or this
this tennis distressful? Alright, I think
we are almost done. So let's get away. This
one here. We're done. navbar. And let's be
include the navbar here. I don't think so.
Okay, as I thought as much I should include
the navbar inside the video. So let's include
its face so include partials. Supposed to
be a string partials start navbar with HTML
okay, I guess we're done issue. The sixth
element. Let me just confirm Something from
the show movie Okay, so this PowerShell is
supposed to be a string it's supposed to be
a string before we land in another era. Okay,
so let's continue with the movie list trying
to move as fast as I can as long as I can.
So you're gonna have another block called
content the block
content okay let's close or minimize this
main tag move everything into the block content
nice one a way this to tax that we expand
it again because you're going to make some
magic in here. Alright so now let's save it
then go back and refresh and see whether we're
going to have our pitch working we're going
to learn in an arrow Okay, so you can see
stuff are coming through but we are not getting
an image or image here. So I had a static
image over there so let's figure out who am
I so it's going to be a background image okay,
this is it. So, first let's take away the
assets this up static around this. So, we
need to load in our static file alright. So,
so, we need to load in our static file right
up here. So load static static like this.
Then can go back and refresh and see whether
magic will happen or not. Like I see the navbar
is also not appearing if you forget to include
it what is happening and you face again what
on earth is happening and we check my console
sure the file doesn't exist or something like
that. I forgot to add those files to it. Okay,
so sorry about that. But I don't know why
they not by snowshoeing Oh, you forgot to
include the number. Okay, I thought as much
so let's include the nav bar nav bar HTML.
So you can save it, then you have to do what's
the image that is not there. So I'm going
to free this recording. Then add the image
image to the static file. After you guys as
you can see, I've added the image to it. So
when you check the complete project, you're
going to find this image added to it. Okay.
So let me close that one. And let's go back,
refresh and see whether you're going to get
this as you want it. She's fresh Okay, so
now we have this div I have some styling issue
since this styling is no common shoe. So I
think I know what the error is where the error
is coming from. So that particular button
which is display went to Iran is a star is
in lifestyle in lifestyle. So there's going
to be a color of black. Okay, guys the only
one that needs it, okay? Yes. So let's say
we're okay. This is going to be our last refresh
before we continue what you are going to continue
Okay, so now you can see everything popping
up nicely. So this is we are going to list
our movies. So we take the movies from our,
from our back end, then we are going to lesson
two over here. Okay. Okay, guys. So let's
do that. What are we going to do? We're going
to look over the movies, okay, so the movies
are rendered with this, this devil over here.
So you're going to get away or the DIS below
and you're going to live all you want just
one there is you're going to use a for loop
to provide it oh, sorry, sorry. So delete
all of them and leave this particular one,
the one that has the image and it's okay,
the one that has the image in it. So you're
gonna take this off I'm leaving the one with
the image because it has some styling that
I need. Okay, so just delete those ones without
the image. Alright. So we're going to run
a for loop on it so it's going to be a for
loop. Join the for loop, the house movie,
movie
in movies. And with each movie, I'm going
to create an anchor tag so that we'll be able
to move to the detail page of a particular
movie, okay. So for me tables, leave it as
hash. Then I want to wrap it around this.
This, this div over here, okay? So if you
quite remember, each movie has a flyer. So
the flyer is what you're going to place inside
the div, right? So here, we are going to render
out our image or the flyer. For us to rent
out a flyer going to a movie, dots flyer.
And we want the URL for that particular flyer.
Okay? Not URL URL. Okay. So this is it, we
save it. Now let's go back and refresh. See
what's going to happen a few seconds more
or so. So we scroll down. And voila, we have
no movies so there's nothing rendering here.
So what I'm going to be the I'm going to pause
the video, then create a super account then
go into the Django database, the Django admin,
then add some one or two movies to the to
the back end. Okay. So it's not so anything
huge that's why I'm trying to make it let's
get it together I don't want you guys to miss
out anything my son is actually running loose
I wanted to do it of upside but he does it
together so that you have a full full view
of everything happening okay so we are going
to create a super user okay we are going to
do that with Python manage pui creates super
user okay I'm going to give its use only Archer
Dave you with something simple my brain is
static II II II ii.com admin the password
is admin processes when going to be admin
Yes Okay, so now this place and I let's go
and use our Django admin localhost 8000 Plus
admin so now let's log in. So, when to go
a at a Let's go the password is admin oh okay,
so it's logged in. So what we want to do is
wonderful, we want to add movies but you have
not added the the movie database to our our
admin Okay, so let's do that. So let's go
into core we're going to add our modules to
the admin so the in the admin.py file is going
to run with a few alpha I totally forgot for
what about those steps. So from ruts models
imports imports was the name of the model
movie. Then also import profile and last but
not the least Cornerstone Christo Musa and
I totally forgot about this video alright
so we're going to add it to add admin so admin
dot site dot register going to have movie
copy down change the stance I want to move
further my laughter is lay down oh was this
so is going to be profile see what it also
it's doing with me to be a video in here Chris
Donnie, sir. Alright, I think we are good
to go now. Right? So now let's go back to
admin and give it a refresh again. Okay, so
now you can see those things over here. So,
first, you're going to create a video. The
video is going to be linked to a movie so
it's totally cool. Just follow along first
beta video we are not going to give it any
title I are going to choose some dummy short
videos that I downloaded from YouTube so what
did I call them I placed them somewhere where
did I place this is short short short short
video this guy okay to see let's see what
our particular movie instance then now go
to the movies the video is does that account
split your movie instance that fly list the
F list this put some dummy with laughter so
it's going to be a single movie and I'm going
to choose one then I'm going to use the F
list a limit is all so the service now we
have a single movie installed inside our database.
So let's go and refresh it. Let's refresh
our homepage again so we can see now we have
nothing there. Let's refresh it again Okay,
since you have a problem, let's log out you
guys are previous our previous user sorry
about that guys the
images are huge. So it's it's makes it slow
to render. So it was using Kojo as khwaja.com.
Killer just last login, you want to go through
the process of creating another profile again.
So okay, so now you have your profile. So
let's use it Okay, so as you can see, I have
a movie down here. Okay, so we have a movida
here. I seem to have some error with our image.
So let's check that one out it's probably
some shark refreshing it again. Well, why
is it's either not working. So let's just
change. Let's inspect this Okay, guys, so
it seems I found the arrow it's from here.
It's not supposed to be movies supposed to
be movie. Okay. Let's save it. Go back. Let's
refresh this thing again. Okay, so you can
see the images come into over here. Okay.
So now we have broken this down movie. So
we need to now make a detail page. Okay, so
now you can also expand upon this. I did it
myself. I've already done but I want to leave
it as a challenge for you guys, where you're
going to send a single video that is going
to be a showcase. That's going to be the showcase
movie. Okay. So I want to extract just one
movie from here from the filtered movies yet.
Now we're going to use this as your Showcase
movie. Instead of using the static. The static
showcase movie over here. I won't use that
one as a showcase movie. So try that one out.
Let me know your solutions down there inside
the comment section below. Okay, did it for
myself. And it was very simple. So I believe
you guys can do that. So the next thing that
we're going to work upon is the Detail page
that when a user clicks on this, this movie
should send into the detail page where he
or she is going to see all the details about
this particular movie. And then you can click
upon it to go and watch it, okay. So let's
jump back into Visual Studio code. And go
into our views, okay, as usual. Okay, so let's
create the movie detail page. So, let's go
down let's create a new class called Show
Movie. Do assuming this, the capital is going
to inherit from the view. Okay, so the next
thing we're going to do is you're going to
define a get method going to take itself taking
request and taking the movie ID the underscore
ID and the last thing is going to take in
the x x and quarks, alright. Okay, so what
you're going to choose, you're going to try
and get the movie The movie ID a movie with
a movie ID okay. So we're going to use a try
except block so that we don't get any error
arrow. So let's clear this thing off when
you try straight in a movie variable, you're
going to get a movie dot objects objects dot
gets where the UID t go to movie underscore
ID right the next thing that we want to do
is that if the movie exists then you want
to return a render so try to explore return
within a render have requests and are going
to serve iterate today movie detail dot HTML
pa templates now going to pass along the contest
visionary so I'm going to pass along the movie
The movie that we had right? But you want
to check for exception exception. The only
other scenario we have to check is there if
the movie does not exist, okay. So if the
movie does not exist, let's clear this assertion
from day and use the movie. de Deus does not
exist. Okay, if it doesn't resort to what
you want, you do want to return a redirect
to the profile page. Okay. So the profile
is speech okay. So it then retain a redirect
to reverse URL to profile underscore list
like this. Okay. So now we have our view done.
So let's add it to our url.py file. Okay,
so Chara you Wi Fi, what you are going to
do is you're going to first import show movie.
detail. Okay, so you're going to use it inside
are going to create a new party. And are you
always going to be slash movie slash detail?
Slash I went to thicken a dynamic value which
is going to be power movie ID Okay, and close
it out with an NS lash. Okay, so we are going
to use a show movie do you feel like I spoke
my detail? Okay, they are going to the door
as you on it. And let's give it a name. Okay,
and it's going to be called Show underscore
debts a short version of show detail. Let's
skip the list running. Alright, let's save
it. Okay, so now we have that working. But
where we want to use it actually is inside
the home was the name the home where the movies
are listed, so that when the user click on
this one, I decided to take it to the was
the name, the Detail page of this particular
movie, okay, so let's add it this other URL
to this one to the movie list speech. So where
we are returning this hash, this h ref hash,
you're going to use we're going to use a URL
instead of the hustle, I want to return a
URL here. So they are going to go to core
core, the show underscore debts, they're going
to provide their movie ID okay. All the underscore
id going to be equal to movie.uu Id Alright.
So let's save it Alright, so now let's refresh
this thing again. Now let's go over this.
So now you can see it is sending us to the
Ito value. Let's click on it and see where
it will send us to. Okay, so now it sends
us a detail page. But the details there are
static data. So we need to make it dynamic
so that it uses the one for the particular
movie that we just chose. Okay, so let's go
into we can close this one over the movie
data list and open up the movie detail templates.
So, so open up show movie detail and let me
expand my so that you see everything okay,
so an open show movie detail a their movie
ditto templates The first thing I want to
change is the beat this thing over here I
want to change I uses the movie title. So
because you are sending in a context with
the name of it, you can get from it the title
Alright, the next scenario you want to change
is this thing over here I won't use the movie
detail that was provided you're going to get
some weird stuff. movie description was it
was hard to spot description okay. And I just
want to make some changes here let's or this
way is this a way to adjust this. Oh. Let's
add an in an inline style here so now we can
see the button. Just it's not showing for
the entire let's just add a color of luck
to it so little become black. Right? Rather
move to is my laptop Vitiate ESCO it'll come
back to where it's supposed to be. Let's kick
it. Okay. So you're making it into inline
style block the color the test block. Okay,
so here we are using dynamic data, we're going
to just take everything off we are going to
render our movie description over here too
via underscore description. So this pathway,
it's on the image or the header part, you
can slice the detail and just take like maybe
50 characters or 100 characters or less, depending
on your preference so that you don't jam up
the front. The first page this page is math.
So I just show some, a little bit of a summary
to it. Okay, then show all the details below,
inside the URL description below. Okay, the
next thing I want to do is the image the background.
Okay. So this time around, you're not getting
this from access, access, as I said as assets,
or from static sorry, from static this area,
I went to use a media URL. Okay. So we're
going to grab this one and it is going to
be that flyer. URL. So it's going to be movie
dot flyer. That URL okay so you see that up
there now let's go back and refresh this thing
Okay, so you can see the flyer is in the description
is also in but something that's wrong wrong
some way I think I spelled something wrong
and the styling too is off so let's less I
think that's fine I know where the error is
coming from so the style and religion I need
to do is just take over this then justify
end from the session I want to select you
address for description war movie dot description
are we are the scripts Oh no. We don't description
is it and he said I he made the same mistake
away as a description over here, so let's
save it. Go back and try it for the fourth
time I see what I was gonna work alright,
so it seems that there's no description for
the movie, and yet. I thought there was a
description. That's let me check that quickly.
Okay. Okay, guys. So I've actually confirmed
it, it seems there when we're making the spelling
for the model, we made a mistake, install
the description will I omitted the T. So you
can correct that make migration and migrate,
then you have everything but I'm just going
to just use it like that. Just take off the
T sites work. So you can just correct it out
on your end. Okay. I'll have to have to do
want to talk to you guys. Let's refresh. So
you can see now the description is not coming
through this. It's any of the other ones over
here. So I just noticed one thing I tried
to log out over here. Let's see. And I had
this red arrow it actually did log out. Wow.
Okay, maybe I don't know why. But when I tried
to log that I had a CSRF error. Okay, So you
can see, you know, the description is coming
through, so you can make it better. We have
already wasted a lot of time, so I can't go
about making description and other stuff.
So the styling and everything has been done
for you just have to place in more detail.
More objects inside. The admin just creates
more instances, okay. But there's one thing
I want to help you do that, which is if there
is the movie is a seasonal movie, we have
to display you see when it is you're watching
a Netflix movie, and you go to the detail
page, and then it's a seasonal movie, they
show you the episodes, and you can choose
which Episode Are you want to watch. That's
what I want us to do. I'm going to copy in
some code and I'm going to explain why I'm
not actually going to actually going to create
a seasonal movie. So that we experimented
with it, okay, but we did my best to make
it clay, dry able to understand it. So, scroll
down a little bit outside the session. Okay.
So above the description over here. When you
paste in some code, you can pause it and type
it in. Okay, so let me paste it in. Okay,
so this is it. So first, I'm checking the
movie type to see whether it is equal to CS
now. So if it is season, I'm going to create
a div here. And I'm going to display an age
to say episodes, and I'm going to loop over
the the movies inside the the movies inside
all the videos that has been linked to that
movie. The movie instance. Okay, so a movie
is linked to a video instance. Okay, so let's
say a particular a particular episode that
has been linked to a main main main movie,
okay. So I'm going to loop over it, then I'm
going to first get the gets what gets the
for loop counter, which is provided to us
by Django. And I'm going to get the movies
episode title. Okay. So then I display all
that, then you can see I am making some HDF
over here. So you let me take, I'm going to
live it for the meantime. I'm making some
URL over here, which is going to call play,
we have not yet created it. There then I'm
adding the movie ID here. And I am adding
what an epi the API is going to be help us
get to the particular episode that was clicked
on. So we'll be able to show the user the
particular episode that they clicked on and
not the first movie, okay. So this is it.
So you can just type in this code, it will
become more clear if you fasted yourself.
Okay. So that is it. Okay, so, what you're
going to do next is you're going to click
create the page that is going to show us the
movie itself. Okay? So then click on the play
button display button over here. Be able to
know which be able to play the movie to us
okay. So let's go back into our views where's
my view? Where's my Okay, so I've opened up
my view and first the before we begin that
I want us to protect this router let's just
copy this method over here copy this then
place it on top of this one slowly adjust
the greeting at the login required decorator
then let's move down Okay, so we're going
to create a new class the class is also going
to be protected and is going to be called
class. Show sure movie tool is going to show
the movie and he's going to hear it from view
and you're going to have a death forget that
takes himself. They can request takes in a
movie ID B underscore ID and when to take
in X axiom quarks okay. Then you're going
to try and get the movie so we're going to
study the movie instance. And we're going
to get the movie dot objects dot get objects
object dot get I'm going to go with a UU ID
and it's going to be cost to the movie underscore
id okay then you're going to be 10 We're going
to illustrate this we movie we're going to
reassign the movie constant or the movie variable
to movie the value movie does videos in the
movie snap editor but I see what's going on
with our video videos dot value okay. So we
are going to get some sort of a list okay.
We are going to return it return a render
of request we are going to retain the templates
show movie dot HTML All right, then we're
going to add the contest a contest this Narita
is going to have your movie this movie this
way so I movie this way okay you're right
okay so now you're going to have an exception
you're going to check for movie dots does
not exist if he does not exist you guys know
I guess what do you want to do want to return
a redirect redirect to pour proof underscore
list Okay, so this is it so we are done with
this bat so let's save it our let's win other
than this view to our our URLs so first let's
import it in then let's create a path for
it. So we are going to give me a pact are
going to call that particular path play. And
also not play the movie nice play slash for
gospel movie will also this will be slash
please slash STR which is going to be via
that score ID. Okay, let's get out of it.
Then movie.us View Show movie.us You We're
going to call it the name is going to be play.
Alright. So let's save it up. And now the
next thing I want to do is we want to use
this URL inside the show movie. So that when
a user clicks on their button play inside
it is take them to this home page, bring them
to this page, okay, or this route. So let's
go into our movie detail page and what you're
going to do is you're going to wrap around
this button, an anchor tag so down Kota is
going to have a URL that is going to point
to play also called let's play call column
play this causation and namespace So, you're
going to have your movie ID going to be equal
to movie.uu Id Okay then let's move in this
button is all button over here save it up.
And as you go to the field page now says refresh
will be don't get in here. Okay, so now we
have in Euro so this thing now can take us
to the page. Let's click on it. Okay, so we
have an error as beautiful as said doesn't
have value, probably Shula value, no probably
doesn't have value, it's supposed to be values.
So let's change this thing over here and let's
refresh this Okay, now I see. Okay, so supposed
to be slash. So let's go into our show movie
instead of it's been movie dots. Now. Pastures
dots now by supposed to be pasture slash this
way now, let's refresh again. Okay, so now
you can see, we have our page showing where
the movie is now. It's not, it's not being
played. Okay? That's sad. No, Netflix, Netflix,
that's a movie. That's bad. So let's go into
our, our templates once again. So this is
where we are going to be the magic happens.
So instead of showing this static, a movie
that is rendering from some asset and which
is not working, so clearly, let's take it
off let's take this whole thing off. Alright.
So we are going to using some JavaScript Okay.
So first thing I want to do is I want to pass
the value that is going to be sent from the
front end is going to be in a form of A is
going to be sent from the back end. Or the
view is going to be in the form of a list.
So we want to pass it then send it to Surah
Damascus be able to have access to it with
So the best way to do it is to use the JSON.
The script JSON script tag, okay? So the name
of it is going to be movie now using the JSON
scripts Okay, so JSON scripts are going to
give it a name. I'm going to call it movie
underscore data. Okay? So beneath this mean,
I'm going to paste in some JavaScript that
I'm going to go to, and explain it for you
guys. Okay. So okay, so this is a JAVA script
over here. So this is it. This is basically
it's all together within was going to see
Oh, god. Okay, so this is everything so. So
first I am getting, I'm selecting this video
tag here, then I am passing this data that
has that I've sent from the from the view
here, which is in the form of a list, then
I'm grabbing it over here. So I'll do it.
Okay. So when I'm done, I am creating a new
URL, which the location dot ref, which is
the current URL that we are on, then I try
to get out a parameter. The parameter is called
epi. So when you check the movie detail, when
I added this, let me show it to use, it becomes
a little bit clearer. When I added this block
of code that was looping over the movie. So
in case it's a seasonal movie, it's going
to have an epi at the end. Will you tell us
which particular episode they use or want
to watch? Okay, so that's what the EPI is
for is like for episode, okay. So that's what
I'm trying to grab from the URL. Okay. So,
try to grab that from the URL. But if it does
not have an API, then it means that the person
is trying to watch a single movie. So we make
the video parameter, what is zero. So if it's
as the API then settings to the API, okay,
and this is passing to an integer. So whatever
is going to come out is going to be an integer,
okay? Then, we try to select the video fodder
you want to watch. So the listener is going
to come out of here is going to provide a
link to give us a list of video files. Okay?
So the video file is going to be in order.
So episode, if it's a seasonal movie, episode
one is going to be first episode two is going
to be second three in that order. Okay, so
we get to that particular episode, then we
get to the file, the file is going to give
us a URL. Okay, the file is going to give
us a URL, then we just made the path to that
URL with this thing over here. This, this
our root URL, which is pointing to our media
files, okay, I hope I didn't confuse anyone.
Okay. So this is how you're doing it. So let's
save it. And let's go back and refresh Okay,
so since you have some arrow somewhere like
ECCS, you can pass what about about the sun?
So I think I know where the arrow is coming
from. So so instead of
inside the view.py file here instead of sending
the movie, we are going to send a list. We're
going to wrap it around a list Okay? So make
it a list instead of a query, to query whatever
I'd have talking about. So let's save it's
going to be able to pass it to Jason. So let's
refresh. Okay, so now you can see this time
around, we have a video showing up. So we
can play the video. Some VH yet very simple
short video that I downloaded from somewhere.
Okay, so we can see everything is working.
Now we can play a video. So let's, let's go
back you can can't go back. Okay, so when
you go back, then you click this thing over
here, play. Once you send us to the page where
the movie is supposed to play, then voila,
we can go ahead and play our movie. Okay,
so guys, this is basically the end of the